[Music]
if you were to ask me to describe 2021
i'd say that it feels like the start of
a new era fittingly so is what some
consider the first year of a new decade
and in the anime sphere that sentiment
sticks so much with attack on titan
wrapping up soon it seems that the big
hitters from the old guard from the
2010s have come and gone or shifted to
movies like sao then there's legacy
stuff like the upcoming bleach and
shaman king that proved that sometimes
old stuff just doesn't go out of flavor
for too long that's why for today i want
to feature some of the best new hits
that 2021 had given us in the realm of
action anime who knows maybe these new
contenders will end up shaping the
future generation in this coming decade
with that in mind i'll be excluding
sequels from the list so sorry slime and
demon slayer let's start with kimono gm
being a fan of a supernatural fantasy
series you bet i did check out kimono gm
coming out of it i'd echo the sentiment
of the show's fans and say that this is
quite the criminally underrated shonen
it's got a lot of flags that appeal to
me giving me a bit of that boongo stray
dogs or inspector vibe but as i'd learn
it's much more of a character driven
show i came in for the supernatural
action involving demons and humans but i
found myself more captivated with the
characters and how their dynamic just
kept getting better the longer the show
went on the characters have genuine
chemistry with one another and if the
fighting didn't convince you perhaps the
growth and the bonds that the characters
exhibit will overall i can see why
kimono gn got overshadowed by other
action shows especially in the season it
was in you know the one with an attack
on titan season mushoko tensei slime and
a re-zero season but all things
considered it's an underrated gem that
you'll have a blast watching
[Music]
next we have sukimichi parody isakai
have the distinction of often being
compared to the most popular of them all
gonosuba and tsukimichi are no exception
i think that it's an apt comparison yet
at the same time i think the tsukimichi
has a lot of merits that allow it to
stand out in its own right what are
those merits it's the way in which it
combines a lot of familiar tropes
channels meme energy in them like
konosuba and comes out as something
surprisingly refreshing and fun to watch
there's order in mayhem and this comedic
series just embodies that saying so well
it's a show with a lot of crazy moments
that captures the fun and appealing
aspects of several issachain if you're
intent on taking a break from the very
intense fights in power fantasies like
slime and you prefer something a bit
more chill and comedic then this could
be the isakai for you
for our next entry we take a look at
either den deities an old adage goes
that you shall not judge an anime by its
art alone yes the art makes a strong
impression and helps you tamper
expectations but we've got a lot of
hidden gems behind very simplistic
looking appearances anyone expected odd
taxi to take the world by storm how
about osama ranking in the action side
of things i'll gladly apply that to ida
denditis what i expected to be a very
quirky and light-hearted action comedy
ended up being one of my go-to shows for
unwinding it's got mapa at the helm and
it's from the same guy who brought us
the most cultured modern anime in
interspecies reviewers yep there's a lot
to like it's got violence edgy and all
that wild stuff that some of you who
like that more daring aspect of anime
would also like a pure fun and turn your
brains off show is what i'd normally say
but at the end of it all it'd be unfair
to just write it off as purely style
over substance
come on a gacha game anime doesn't have
any right to be this good but by god
they did it tactop destiny is the action
series that starts off in full throttle
and doesn't let go its premise seems to
be your everyday mobile game plot of a
protagonist commanding a harem of girls
to fight interdimensional invaders all
the like but so far it's managed to hit
the mark in a lot of ways i find myself
enjoying the plot the protagonist's
dynamic with the girls and the
simplicity and honesty of it all it
acknowledges its identity and while it
doesn't have the most original story
beats besides its incorporation of
classical music in a battle heavy series
it goes on in an engaging manner further
proving my belief that it's execution
that matters the most oh and before we
go ahead i'd like to ask you for your
help in growing the channel how can you
do it well the subscribe button up there
takes less than a second to click and
it's going to help the channel so much
starting off the post break we have 86 i
can't be the only one who first picked
86 because of lean am i and guess what i
got way more than i bargained for 86
overall is a strong show that got me
very invested it's got the action the
mecca and the political themes that
strike quite close to home given the
circumstances of the world it's a show
that drastically tugged on my
heartstrings on route to the first part
ending and the second part brought the
series back even stronger cliffhangers
galore kept me waiting for weeks on end
and the tribulations that the main cast
go through make this an extremely
engaging watch that i'd definitely
recommend to anyone it's got some strong
themes that deal with elements that you
don't typically see in a dengeki bunko
light novel and it's a pleasant change
of pace on the more supernaturally
charged action shows that we have
[Music]
and right after 86 we have a show that
seems to lean towards the other
direction far from the gritty war-torn
world we come across a world of fantasy
in the bazaar a world where vampires and
magic exist and make up the core
foundation of our series vanitas surely
lends a lot of its appeal to its very
eye-catching world and visuals there's
also the sublime music and overall
atmosphere that the anime team managed
to get however i feel that its strongest
point is in its handling of the
characters coming with their own air of
mystique the characters just develop and
flow so smoothly with one another the
action's not as high octane as you'd
expect from an action series but i say
that if you're looking for a
supernatural series with a strong sense
of mystery and drama vanitas will be
your cup of tea
[Music]
now this one took me by surprise it's a
late addition to the current season's
roster debuting at the tail end of
november super crooks has thoroughly
entertained me in his 13 episode run and
i didn't expect to be entertained as
much as i did based off comics from the
creator of kick-ass super crooks is a
superhero anime that deals quite heavily
with the duality of good and evil you
know there's western titles where the
heroes are the ones causing destruction
on their way to serving justice oh and
have a cast of thieves while you add it
too yet it does have some elements of
those along with a star that reminds me
of great pretender understandably super
crooks has that whole bagano and amazon
prime series the boys vibes maybe
gangster too if you've watched it
actually is it as good as they are
personally i don't think so with burgano
but that's not a knock on super crooks
looking at super crooks as a series it
provides a good amount of action tension
and a cast of characters for you to
empathize with if you're up for
something that looks different from the
traditional anime fair with just the
same amount of excitement you should
definitely give super crooks a shot
in third place is tokyo revengers did
anyone say hi octane action well
gangsters time travel and brutal fights
are what you'll get out of tokyo
revenges and then some if you're up for
edgy characters some good old-fashioned
violence and a deja vu of erased or
re-zero then you're in for a treat with
this one tokyo revenges is what you'll
look out for if you want an action anime
that gets your heart pumping
consistently the premise didn't really
sell me much at first and the
inconsistent speed at which events
happened played a big part in me
sticking with that opinion early on but
once i bought into it i'd say that tokyo
revenge just really deserves to be one
of the shows we remember 2021 for what i
appreciate about tokyo revenges is how
it maintains a certain consistency with
its tone it holds tension very well and
doesn't have those mis-timed comedic
segments that a lot of shonen
counterparts have so for me that in
addition to the charismatic characters
that you can't help but empathize with
is the main strength of the series the
story is a joy to follow all the way to
the end of the anime while i wouldn't
crown this anime of the season by any
means following dakimichi's growth
through his struggles made for a very
entertaining watch
[Music]
second place is mushoku tensei
granddaddy of isakay or not one thing's
for sure mushoku tensei is a show that
was crafted with exceptional care by the
anime team and we can let the results
speak for themselves unlike a lot of
issachai or light novel adaptations that
were plagued by cut content or outright
weird decisions by the anime team
mushoku tensei manages to be a decently
paced show that captures the essence of
the source material very well it didn't
come without its controversy and i think
that it's by far the most polarizing
mainstream hit that we have right now
it's not controversial in a meme way
that interspecies reviewers was or
something like the detective is already
dead where the controversy squarely
leans towards the negative side amidst
criticisms mushoku tensei ends up being
a generally entertaining watch with an
excellent foundation in world building
but i do agree that it's not for
everyone due to some sensitive content
the world building is great the action's
cool and the characters surrounding
rudius are mostly genuinely interesting
people that i do want to know more about
the show is a testament of passion's
effect on a product and amid
mass-produced mcdonald's tier
adaptations of otherwise good novels it
stands out as probably the standard
bearer for the isakai genre for years to
come because come on you think the
isekai train will be ending any time
soon i don't think so
[Music]
topping our list is vivi will people
agree with me putting it above isakai
king mushoku tensei or mainstream
blockbuster tokyo revenges i mean i
personally think the vv can make a very
strong case for the best action animate
of 2021 take all the elements you want
from action anime like the spectacular
fights the smooth animation the hype
inducing music and adding the magic
element of strong character development
and themes that make us second guess
ourselves it's a lot more profound than
a lot of sci-fi action shows and i
really enjoyed that element of it it
constantly kept me engaged with question
after question all the way to its
spectacular ending admittedly though i
also think the expectations played a
part in me being blown away by vv coming
into the season i didn't know what to
think of it other than it seems strange
that re zero's created dabbles in sci-fi
still i feel it more than manages to
stand in its own right as the best
action anime this 2021 so which was your
favorite action anime of 2021 i'm
excited to hear about your thoughts so
make sure you make full use of the
comment section for those who liked what
i did with the video you can head over
to the rest of my channel and pick up a
video that you might be interested in
memberships are also open with perks
that you might be interested in too and
so is my patreon in the description box
it's been a great time looking back at
some of the best action hits the anime
world has given us this year truly it's
the start of a new era and i'll be
looking out for more and i hope that
you'll do the same till next time
you